I've got a new those goods sorry hi I'm
I'm for Jarvis and I'm Anna senior
procurement consultant I work for Rachel
Council the Essex p.m. come and I'm
provide procurement support to watch
1242 Jason excellent thank you very much
indeed right other than that of start
off the phone line right please note
this meeting will be able doubt even
boarded should be required to evacuate
the building would you please leave the
room by the door to the virus kind of
staircase stepped over there which you
can't see please hold both half miles in
case the stairs of wet or slippery if
anyone is unable to use the stairs where
they please allow us to exit exit the
room before they go to the forest cake
tour where they can then be given
assistance our sympathy point will be in
the public car park at the side of the
Civic squeeze please do not operation
didn't have any belongings and please do
not return to the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
right okay start off on the apologies
for absence please everyone to your
champs I think there are no apologies
for absence non members attending I
don't think they're already minutes of
the meeting held on the 9th of sep
tember 2015 is your wish I sign them as
a treatment would break you any
declarations of interest if anything
comes to mind during the meeting Peter
in that point when including in the
minutes masses report to the executive
and reports of other committees they're
all none progress on decisions obviously
we've got the show too so I'll go
straight to that at night that's item 6
right so I'll go through the pages so
paint one page to radio action plan
right page 34 please stop near fun thank
you faster 56 I understand the planning
applications and that means submitted
for the council depo is that very quick
ok so that's going to the process now
anybody else from play 6 7 8 10 11 so i
will get a triple 11 on the second of
december that is what it says the ATM 12
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25
6 27 and 28 will that work too bad was
it so members know the report thank you
die from seven so item seven report to
the meeting addictive foreplay or
finance and its revised contract see
Charles and I believe sign of castor
silence with is going to be dis item
very very briefly chairman the need for
this this report is not as a result of
practices that aren't adequate or any
deficiencies that we've got is just
framework in which we work in rules and
regulations that we work to have altered
and although my name is at the top I'm
not going to take any credit for putting
a lot of hard work into this Matt and
Paul or a hard work in here so if you
don't mind I'd like pass over to them
through for a brief explanation without
line and for them to take credit for for
all you've been doing okay thank you
very much okay thank you can smear think
Jenna just to briefly outline the report
itself hopefully suffix pantry that
seeks outline the reason for revising
the council's contract procedure rules
as councilman said is not due to any
deficiencies in the previous rules is
more to reflect new legislation and best
practice we also took the opportunity to
develop more robust contracts you two
rules document and again just bring it
not in line with as I kind of slave from
the best practice and ensure its own fit
the purpose and Malta more robust there
are some key changes listed on the
report I don't intend to go through them
particular candy that's if you wish as
mentioned two or three key changes to
the document there the main one being
the Auslan is the most economically
advantageous criteria mean there's a a
quality criteria needs to be attached
can be attached to certain tender
processes over some key thresholds it
also goes on to discuss and describe how
exceptions cannot be granted for certain
thresholds and how we're encouraged to
break up contracts into lots moving
forward it's quite lengthy documents
there are the LT other notes in there
happy to answer any questions on it and
we lucked up all the votes this evening
should she wish to establish and further
questions okay thank very much yes
please the bullet points commencing on
set point 1 all spend over 25,000 pounds
has to be appetizers etc and so then we
would look at seven point soon councils
more be encouraged to break contracts
into lofts seems to be somewhat
contradictory because if you've got a
hundred thousand pounds and you divide
it by five you'd up the 25,000 it's five
knots that's not what's intended Sean
and I believe that the government's
reason for protective you see is lips
movie surprised if I might render to the
mystery in terms of their the detail son
yes a very detailed and possessed to a
full knowledge of the entire all the
clauses in its normal Passover to Paula
who has a much greater knowledge
background arabi Atlantic you might as
well yes I'll let you go Eddie
yes so the government's reason for doing
this is to encourage us to break big
contracts down into smaller plots for
the local SMEs to then be able to bid on
those works and to be able to win them
whereas opposed to such as 100,000
pounds a local SME may not actually have
the experience and the knowledge to
fulfill the whole contract whereas they
may actually be able to do part of it by
splitting into five lots you can
essentially duck the first bullet point
I don't think that's why they intend but
that's how it comes out in the report
and we need to be perfectly clear about
that I think if I may who said he didn't
know where we're a small accounts on
these these regulations this framework
is going to be in place for all councils
and I daresay as with any new new set of
rules they'll be loopholes that which
with some turns and so on and I think
there'll be examples and test cases from
a number of other councils that will set
the way in which it works that will then
be able to follow there's be the small
council unfortunately we don't have
office of money to spend I think clearly
the Olympics when they were doing the
contracts the Olympics they did a
similar exercise clearly some of those
contracts for very large ed and some of
them were quite small yes so but I know
they did split them up so that indeed
lowboy Sinise and others actually
contender for those and
you know it's interesting way of taking
things forward so perhaps that sort of
come forward from this you're like you
wouldn't say thank you to mrs. Brinkley
and I've heard back before tonight on
cialis all happy and challenges are
always faulted a bit for the most
economically advantageous tender as
opposed to the yeah okay anybody else
want to say anything on this it's not
just an observation I remember the new
book tendering ourselves as a
photographic company for projects we
found it extremely difficult because of
the largeness of the tenders and even
though companies actually won the tender
they have no expertise in the field in
which they were operating what they did
they didn't subcontracting out and
that's exactly what happens to you know
the smaller businesses really struggled
but they were able to pick up the
subcontract where we just weren't able
to get into into the major contracts I
just wondered you know could this be a
better way for smaller businesses to get
in on things rather than have to go on
the coattails from larger companies who
might mess up these and then arrival to
subcontract out and this is really don't
get the kid they should do in a ping I
think I just sort of counter that
slightly by reflecting on we obviously
want to make a very small and
medium businesses and and so on but at
the end of the day we want best deal for
our council of Romany in and as long as
this doesn't hinder us from doing that
exactly we're spending public money here
ok any other points please so this is
for a recommendation to full council
that the revised contract procedure
rules as texting pending some be adopted
and appending the above decision is
sustainable commissioning procurement
strategy 2015 20 20 attached as appendix
to be approved as there is our green
illness right thank you right can I now
read the exclusion resolution members of
the puppy we have come to the end of the
business that we can debate with you a
present the remaining report contains
exempt information over therefore ask
that you now leave the meeting and it is
hereby resolved that under section 184
the local government act 1972 the public
be excluded from the meeting for the
following item the business on the
grounds that it involved the likely
disclosure of the exempt information as
defined in paragraph 3 a part 1 of Chevy
a scheduled 12a of yet three great room
thank you